the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
there were a couple questions on
estimation so one person was s asked for
answers to estimations I try to give you
orders of magnitude and give you a sense
but if I've missed some lette if you
want to like email me and be like hey I
never I never really got this one let me
know and I can review them and then also
the other thing is I'm never gonna give
you a like six point seven answer
because I'm really asking you an
estimation that has that kind of answer
like some of them do but usually it's
not even that important that you get to
six point seven it's important that you
get to an order of magnitude of ten and
as long as you're there I'm happy and so
that's why I'm not getting to the exact
answer which I know is uncomfortable and
not what you're used to
educationally but it's what the
estimation is there for another person
mentioned that some people have seen
like they were taking a really long time
and getting sort of lost in the
estimations so I try to give you the
right amount of time for the estimation
so that it's reasonable but it is
something to practice getting more
facile with I guess all right so wind
energy so does anyone know why we have
wind on the earth yeah yes from yes so
it's kind of funny cuz wind energy is
basically a funky solar energy which I I
I find pleasing I don't know what I do
there's also some Coriolis effects stuff
going around on with the earth rotating
but the indirect solar energy component
is more more easy to think about and I
think I think is the bigger component
though I'm not sure of that so basically
you have uh needing even heating of the
earth a hot air rises caused a pressure
drop cold air rushes in and that
movement is is what we're getting in
wind so that's what's going on there and
then
a lot of confusion sometimes happens
like a lot of people see these turbines
are not turbines but mills on farms and
it's confusing like what's this versus
this is just a junky version of this and
so the difference is if it's mill its
extracting mechanical power versus a
turbine is extracting electrical power
so these mills are very high torque
devices that move relatively slowly in
terms of their rotation and are used to
do things like pump water or grind grain
they've been around forever
they're still really common in the US
and in many places for pumping water so
if you drive across the country you'll
see these everywhere and they're still
in use and they're really nice and a
whole lot cheaper to build a mill than
to build a turbine because you're going
from mechanical work to mechanical work
so that's very direct and much much
cheaper than doing the extra steps to
get from mechanical work to electric
power generation so a wind turbine in
contrast it's electrical power they have
been around a long time too but not not
you know basically for most of humanity
a long time and again they're they're
going to be moving very quickly at a
much slower torque the the solidity
thing to think about is that when you
want high torque you want to be getting
as much of the air hitting your blades
as possible so that's why there's often
many many blades or really thick blades
on a windmill where there's a wind
turbine you want low solidity so you
want a low proportion of your blade to
be in that swept area so that's why a
turbine is it looks very different so
wind turbines I'm gonna focus on but I
will go back to windmills a little bit
at the end
you have two types right the horizontal
and the vertical axis the vertical the
horizontal axis is what you're used to
seeing around here and what's in the
news a lot because they can go too much
higher heights and wind is much better
the higher you go basically and so the
horizontal wind access turbines are the
more common thing at least in my
knowledge before I started doing any
research into them so there's out the
rotor and the motor are at the top it
has to point into the wind the higher
you go the better but you can imagine
the higher you go adds costs and
difficulty you often try to change your
blade pitch to maximize the efficiency
because depending on how fast the wind
is you want a different blade pitch and
they're now really insanely huge boom so
this is an insanely huge 7 megawatt
turbine which I think you can sort of
see like is there a truck down there
anything it's it's hard to get scale
when it gets this big but it's
ridiculous and some of the challenges
you can imagine and building this thing
is just getting all the materials to the
site because you're probably not gonna
build your manufacturing plant of how
you build your your I'm still a little
off long blade blade thank you you know
you're not gonna build your blade right
on the site where you're gonna want to
install your turbine probably so then
you have to get your blade there so then
you're actually limited by like the size
of a train railroad car or a large truck
or whatever so there's all these crazy
limits when you're getting up to be this
enormous so it's kind of remarkable and
challenging and this is on of a scale
that we're not going to be touching of
course but it's nice to sort of see the
extreme of of what is out there so this
is a 7 megawatt turbine that's actually
running now I believe
and they're currently building a 10
megawatt that'll be in production and a
year running in a year or two so which
is a pretty big jump seven to ten oh
yeah it's it's definitely an area that's
taking off so how this is just classic
sort of Bernoulli drawing to remind you
how they're spinning in the winds and
that they're the motion is really
dominated by the lift not drag one thing
to think about is the need to control
the spin rate so you can imagine on days
where there's not much wind you might
want to change the pitch of the blade to
make sure you're maximizing the wind
you're capturing but on hurricane days
you have to make sure that your you know
wind turbine doesn't completely just
spin out of control and so this is a
really nice relatively simple way to do
it so you can do it mechanically or
electrically or you can do it like
manually so like old wind turbines from
windmills from you know a hundred or 200
years ago there was some poor guy whose
job it was is to turn the turbine into
the windmill into the wind or not
depending on how fast it was so
thankfully that there's been ways to
optimize that either mechanically or
electrically so this is a method where
basically the weight of the tail and the
turbine allows the tail to stay
connected to the the turbine so that the
tail I'm getting lots of huhuhuh faces
so I'll go slowly so the turbine
generally has a tail that's exactly
perpendicular so this plane and the
plane of the tail are perpendicular
right so that the tail makes sure it's
always pointing into the wind which is
what you want
except when you're going too fast now
you need the
tail and the front of the turbine to not
be perpendicular but to start to
hypothetically if you're gales you need
it to be 100 you know completely rotated
so that the wind is just passing by the
turbine or if you're in a moderate wind
where it's too fast for the turbine but
still usable
you want it to be off a little bit and
so the way this works is that when the
wind speed gets high enough you get some
lift in either the tail or the turbine I
forget how how it operates exactly and
so that allows this tail stop to be
disengaged so then the turbine rotates a
little bit which you can sort of see
from this top view these are the front
views and this is the top view so then
the turbine rotates a little bit and
then the weight balances out and so then
the top engages again and then it
maintains this angle of orientation and
then if the wind speed gets even higher
it will again the weights will get out
of balance things will lift the stop
will disengage so it's a really cool
system to keep keep your device safe
when there's a lot of lot of them out
there and so I just wanted to show an
example of what happens when you don't
remember where's my mouse to include
that or don't do it right so watch
carefully
so that was an expensive day and they're
really lucky that no one was under there
so I'll put it back so you can watch it
again
can you see who were you saying you
couldn't see just did you make it work
or what so it rotated so fast that I
believe one of the blades broke off and
then once one breaks it's totally out of
balance and the whole thing just falls
apart and it's moving at such high speed
that really crazy dynamics are going on
so yeah so there's really solid reasons
to design these right especially when
you're talking big scale but even small
scale you can imagine in a hurricane
it's not gonna be a safe thing to be
near and the small ones are often near
people okay so the typical components of
a wind turbine you have your rotor you
have your blades you have a break
because you want the turbine to be start
turning at a certain speed ideally and
so you may need to break provide braking
before you're providing rotation out of
the wind that's another you know smaller
step you can take you have a gearbox to
get the speed to the right speed to
power your generator typically on a
fancier wind turbine there's an
anemometer that provides the electrical
control with these yaw drives and motors
to rotate the turbine into the wind or
out of the wind to maximize the speed of
your turbine and then your tower and
then so all the electricity is being
generated in this part of the body and
then the power is just going down the
the tower and you can imagine the
challenge of when you need to do
maintenance on this and you're talking
about something really high up that you
have to deal with it so the smaller
turbine or turbines that we'll be
looking at
all on guidewires and on a pivot so that
you can rotate them down so you don't
have to climb up to do maintenance
because that requires a much sturdier
Tower and it's a much more dangerous job
some installation considerations that
one would think would be obvious but
aren't always so this is a a wind
turbine that's been installed basically
on a rooftop by some trees it's got two
types of objects that are blocking the
wind entirely so this you know was a
many thousand dollar installation that's
probably providing zero electricity
because the wind may be sufficient 30
meters up but right there is never gonna
be sufficient so the good 30 meters 30
feet a good rule of thumb is you want
your turbine to be 30 feet above any
obstruction within 300 feet and so
obstructions include like houses and
plants and anything else that might be
in the way so next up is vertical axis
wind turbines and you can see there's a
huge range of them and you probably
haven't seen most of these in production
because again they're they're not they
don't have the same level of
efficiencies and benefits that
horizontal axis wind turbines have but
they're a whole lot cheaper and easier
to build so for small scale solutions
there they can be really ideal there's a
bunch of different names of these
different types so for example this is
called a darius wind turbine this is a
savonius wind turbine which you'll be
building on friday and this is a cool
combo savonius darius this the savonius
will start up automatically in wind and
the darius won't but the darius gets a
little bit better efficiency so that
combining sort of gets gets you the best
of both worlds with some drawbacks of
course - and so these power traffic
lights in Taiwan so there are places
where these are installed effectively
and they're kind of cool because as you
can see here
you can almost build them out of
anything and you will build them out of
anything on Friday hey I mean do we have
enough plastic bottles speaking of which
for Friday so I added to your homework
is on Friday you need to bring in a
plastic bottle like a Gatorade bottle a
2-liter bottle whatever it doesn't it
doesn't have to be 2 litres it can be 1
liter or hat you know like a 20 ounce
can't a bottle but we need plastic
bottles so everyone bring what brings
one we'll be in good shape is that
doable if you check the recycling bins
walking to class you'll find one cool so
the some of the advantages there close
to the ground so you don't have any line
losses associate comparative to the
horizontal axis wind turbine you don't
need any yo or pitch control because
they're just in the wind they're
intended to be in the wind and that
works so they work for and they work
generally for lower wind speeds which is
means lower Heights they're often much
less noisy than wind turbines horizontal
axis wind turbines and they can often
start at lower speeds but some of the
advantage disadvantages they're hard to
scale up so you're never gonna get a
seven megawatt vertical axis wind
turbine that's just not viable they're
generally less efficient and they're
more prone to fatigue so they do wear
out more easily because they're
capturing so much more of the wind
typically but they for our purposes
they're definitely a possibility to look
at for anything just a reminder of the
equations we're thinking about so the
force is that you're receiving is
equivalent to 1/2 times Rho AV squared
so V is obviously the velocity of the
wind the cross-sectional area swept and
the density of the wind the maximum
possible
power extraction is dominated by the
velocity cubed so obviously velocity is
gonna be you're in velocity is really
gonna be what you worry about when
you're designing so area is important
obviously but the cube velocity
velocities cubed so the wind speed is
huge so whenever you're thinking is this
a place where the velocity is a wind
turbine appropriate the first question
is well what's the wind speed and then
there's a coefficient of performance
which just is a reality that wind
turbines are not perfect and so there's
a hypothetical limit and you google the
best limit you can find the proof if
that's appealing is kind of cool of
point almost point six is your
hypothetical maximum efficiency and then
a typical limit in reality is anywhere
from a half for a really sweet
horizontal axis wind turbine to less
than 1/10 for a vertical axis wind
turbine that I'll show you later that's
really old-school but does a job when
you need it so the other equation that
you want to think about is the capacity
factor so I've seen some websites that
say like you know wind is so much better
than solar because wind is 24/7 well not
really
unless you're getting up way into the
atmosphere and even then there's a lot
of variation you're not wind is not 24/7
there's a tremendous amount of variation
and so it's generally 20 to 40 percent
of the time is how often your turbine is
provide generating power which is
sounding starting to sound more like
solar actually so that's one thing to
definitely keep in mind okay
so a typical power curve so at some
point at some given speed is when the
turbine starts actually turning because
up until then it can't
physically turn because the wind forces
aren't high enough and then your output
in terms of power is very very low and
then you have an average wind speeds
generally somewhere around here which is
giving you half of the wind power or the
power that you'd like and then you have
a maximum wind speed and then you're
happy happy happy and that's at some
point it gets so high that you have to
shut the turbine down or else you're in
trouble so that's just a good general
way to think about what's happening over
different speeds because you I'll show
you later we're gonna look at data that
shows you the different speeds so these
are maps from NASA that show wind speed
across the entire globe and you can see
if it's very dark it's very low wind
speed and if it's very light it's higher
wind speed so if we could just fill this
part of the weekend with wind turbines
that would be pretty sweet but you can
actually see in Nicaragua which is right
over here
you're getting pretty decent wind
compared to say if we were working in
these parts of Africa or up here in
Russia or something we we wouldn't be
thinking wind turbines at all and you
can see how much variation there is
between January and July and so of
course there's a lot of seasonal
variation no matter what and you can see
like this blue is seven meters per
second which is getting to be useful for
horizontal axis wind turbine you need
five meters per second for vertical you
can go a little bit lower but five is a
good rule of thumb and again why we're
looking at velocity over everything else
is because velocity is cubed for your
power equation so great I've told you
wind speeds I've showed you a NASA map
of the entire earth but that doesn't
tell you much first a given location so
one way to get a really rough estimate
of wind speed is this Beaufort scale
which was developed in the 1800s and
correlates what you can visually see and
what kind of damage are seeing to the
speed some of the caveats on this are
number one it's pretty rough and
especially if you're talking to people
in a community saying like you know tell
me about wind speed and giving them
examples it's hard to remember exactly
what the wind is like like can you tell
me what the Beaufort scale was today
walking here I can't I don't remember I
don't really pay attention to the wind
that much if you're working with farmers
they're probably a little bit more aware
of it than you and I might be but still
it's challenging and the other thing is
that a lot of these metrics are on the
ground and we're probably talking about
significantly higher than the ground
depending on what kind of turbine you're
implementing and so again that that only
helps you so if you're finding out that
you're probably at four miles an hour
which is two meters per second and
really low but at the very ground level
and you're building a turbine that's 30
meters up maybe 30 feet up maybe you
have a shot of getting enough wind yeah
gale from like what the bliz so is that
a regional thing well so it's both so
yes there are some scales that can help
you estimate you know what the ground is
what it is up above but it also is
really dependent on what's around and so
I'm about to show you a tool that helps
a little bit with that but it's still
very imperfect ideally you'd have an
anemometer and you leave it up for five
years and you'd have it you know ten
different heights you know ten different
I know miners ten different heights and
that would get you actual real data that
you'd be psyched for but that would be a
really ridiculously slow expensive
project and so a lot of this is just
estimations and doing your best guesses
so this I'm sorry for the weblink
as you'll see this website is like web
it's not even web 1.0 it's like web 0.5
but it has like awesome data from NASA
so
you go to this website with that awful
link and then there's a bunch of
different ways to get this data and this
is actually for both useful for solar
and wind so if you're worrying about
solar data - this is really useful so if
you don't know where you want to you
don't know your latitude and longitude
you can click use a map to click every
time you do this you have to log in but
there's it's very easy to join because
you just type your password twice
instead of once once you become a member
and then it's slow but I it's it looks
so clunky that I was afraid you'd be
turned off by it and it has good enough
data that I wanted to go through showing
you it so you have this map of the earth
you click in the part of the earth that
you care about to Center it clicked
we're in the wrong part of the world but
we're getting there and you can see like
this is data for a region not for a
small town so there's all sorts of
limits to this data but it's useful and
so now you can finally get your data and
now you can get crazy information so
parameters for solar cooking for solar
panels crowd information which can be
really useful temperature which can be
really useful and now we're getting to
wind so you can see the variety so you
can get 50 meter and 10 meter but
because this is all satellite data or
Airport data so 50 meters is pretty high
for anything we're talking about and
then 10 meters for terrain similar to
the airport because they're measuring at
the airport because that's the place
where they have anemometers so all this
data again you have to take with a grain
of salt but it's good you know if you
use that in conjunction with your own
visual observations and talking to
people it's it's better than nothing
which is the alternative or you know a
million dollar ten-year study which
isn't viable either so we're gonna just
look at wind speed at 50 meters for that
area of Nicaragua I just selected and
you can see the like a 10-year average
and minimum and maximum variation so
it's pretty helpful just to get get you
into the ballpark of do I have a shot of
thinking this might work and then some
of the other things that you can select
for are like you know what how high you
are to Jessica this is getting to what
you were interested in like an an
estimate of where you are and what your
ground cover is and then it sort of
extrapolates what the what the wind will
be so it's pretty useful and powerful is
that 100% accurate given that it's doing
really broad base meetings of course not
but it's a start so it's nice it's a
nice resource to know about so now I
want to spend a little time to talk
about examples of wind power in
developing countries so one is the
humdinger wing belt which is totally
different from what you're used to
seeing and was developed by a student
actually took one of the first D lab
classes I went with back when it was the
Haiti class and we have a wind belt here
but I couldn't find it so maybe during
break I'll be able to dig it up or if
not maybe we can bring it up pretty get
up by Friday and show it in lab on a
Friday so the way the wind belt works is
that instead of a rotation it just uses
the vibration of the belt very similar
to I don't know if you if you guys can
remember the the name of the the bridge
that collapsed yeah does everyone know
the Tacoma Narrows Bridge yeah so well
google it because you can see videos and
it's awesome if you haven't so yeah it
is totally scary especially because
I have a friend who did some research
into it and so this bridge it's a super
long bridge and it just had natural
frequencies at the same rate as the wind
was often blowing and so the bridge
would just go up and down and up and
down crazily and eventually one day it
got so bad that it completely broke
apart and the crazy thing is that people
used to hang out on the bridge on the
really windy days because it was so fun
like you know it's like a roller coaster
just scary thinking about that so anyway
but this is this is the sort of the
inspiration for the humdinger which just
has a really tightly pulled belt in the
middle of a support structure so that
the and you put this win so the wind is
going perpendicular to the board and so
that hits the natural frequencies of the
belt and causes it to vibrate and then
you just have some magnets next to a
coil on the corner that allow you to
generate electricity so for certain
applications this can be a really
low-cost way to provide electricity and
you can you this is a pretty relatively
fancy way of building it but you can
imagine and they have building it out of
like a PVC pipe which you can get
anywhere and builds building it really
simply and because there's no very few
moving parts and nothing rotating it's
much easier to build than even a
vertical axis wind turbine and so it's a
really neat application and you know
hypothetically you could imagine
building it into structures like
railings on buildings and stuff in order
to power different things so this is one
example and we do have at least a couple
at D lab so we'll make sure to show you
them later today or tomorrow another
example is sort of the classic wind
turbine in developing countries was
designed by Hugh Pickett and these are
pictures of work being done at blue
energy on which
in blue fields in Nicaragua and we
worked with them last year and they
build all these turbines so you can see
there's the the support wires and that
you can rotate the the turbine down so
that you can do maintenance on it which
is a really nice feature so that's one
sort of classic design that's pretty
common in developing countries and then
a lot of people have heard of William
come come Kwan ba no there's the wind
belt so let me go back to that so I'll
pass this around but you and the belt is
not exactly taught at the moment but you
can see just the belt the magnet on the
belt that goes against the coil and
that's really all there is to it and
then a little bit of circuitry in order
to generate power which is a really
simple way to do things
yeah and the tape by race
and the vibration allows you to generate
electricity
Thanks
so William Kumpf wamba was this guy
where did he live did I write it down in
Malawi and he just got really interested
in how he could get electricity at his
house and went to the library and read a
bunch of books and got inspired and
built his own wind turbine which doesn't
look like your traditional wind turbine
there are a few design improvements that
could be made especially with better
resources but worked well enough for him
to power a radio at his house and charge
cell phones which got people really
excited so that then he could they would
start paying him so he could start
building more and more turbines so it's
a really cool story and now he's at
Dartmouth doing in school which he'd
never could have done had he not built
this turbine so he's a cool guy
we may be able to get him to come down
to talk to our class this year we'll see
I'm trying but his advisor at Dartmouth
is very reluctant to let him travel I'm
sorry yeah so but because he didn't grow
up here like he's getting very parented
at a different level than you guys are
so by the professor at Dartmouth so
anyway so just a cool example of
something very low-tech
that works really well and made a
remarkable change for this guy and also
his village and then working all the way
down to the really simplest wind
turbines so this is a I don't know if
you say it as pin M&E or Panem owned but
one of those wind turbine which is
incredibly old technology that was this
is the like 10,000 BC technology that
we're talking about and it's just sales
that rotate the sales actually each one
rotates 180 degrees so they're always
moving in the
and this is this is not a turbine this
is a mill so the act of it spinning
pulls this rope pump maybe if I turn off
the lights a little easier to see
so there's a rope pump here and the way
of rope pump works is incredibly simple
you just have a rope inside a tube that
goes down into the water table so that
you're you're filling you're getting
water through holes in the in the tube
and then you either have knots in the
rope or if you can find them rubber
washers like every foot along the tube
and this is obviously not to scale in
any way and so the water gets trapped
between the washers and you pull up the
water that way and so this is really
simple again we're talking about
ridiculously low efficiencies but if you
need to irrigate this is a way to do it
that just uses the wind that works
really well so and this was built for
forty dollars so which is ridiculously
inexpensive compared to even like a Hugh
Pickett wind turbine which is you know
in the thousands of dollars so there are
opportunities for a whole range of
possibilities and then yeah there's just
so many different types out there so if
you look into it
wind is one of the areas where people
get really excited and like to build
their own stuff and so you can see a
huge variety of designs in the world
so that's wind in a very fast nutshell
are there any questions about that
os so next is micro hydro and micro
hydro is kind of funny because it's
harder to find really good examples of
installations the developing world
because they tend to be just built but
not well documented is what I'm finding
so I'm gonna talk more about how you
would determine if a micro hydro
installation would be appropriate and I
don't have as many good examples of
installations that are successful but
they're certainly out there so
hydropower is just using the
gravitational flow of water to generate
power considering both the the two terms
I'm gonna use our head and flow rate so
head is the distance that the waterfalls
and flow rate is how quickly the water
is moving and so hydropower can be at
you know two megawatts and much beyond
and can be a sizeable in is a sizable
impact on our nation's electricity
supply for example all the way down to a
200 watt turbine are smaller so I'm
saying micro hydro for this lecture
probably some of the stuff I'm talking
about is actually Pico or mini ranging
it's and everyone defines these
differently so if you look up what Pico
hydro is you'll see ten different
definitions so it's not critical that
you're getting exactly and you can even
see ie there's there's an between Pico
and micro there's something right so
according to this definition yeah so and
this is with water power it's the same
as wind in terms of there's mills and
there's turbines so you can think of the
old grist mills and other things that
you can see in parts of New England
still there again they're low velocity
high torque delivering mechanical power
directly as opposed to a turbine which
is higher much higher velocity much
lower torque to allow you to generate
tricity so those are the two extremes
yeah in terms of micro or hydropower
there's two methods so one is called
run-of-the-river and that means that
you're just taking a chunk of the river
and siphoning and sizing it off into a
tube that goes directly into your
turbine the as and the other option is a
dam so the benefits of this are that
it's relatively simple you can build it
locally compared to a dam as much harder
to build generally it's comparatively
lower much lower environmental impact
than a dam they're relatively affordable
but when you have a drought you don't
have any storage like you have with the
dam so that's the drawbacks and the dam
is you know the reverse that you can
accumulate your rainfall which is great
but it's relatively expensive and
there's a greater environmental impact
on the negative because damming up water
affects the local environment from the
fish to just what the fields look like
etc etc I'm sure you've heard of dams in
China are similar that you know have
destroyed entire like many and entire
communities for building dams on a very
very large scale and then yeah and
there's more maintenance associated with
a dam too in terms of silica mediation
it's challenging so we're just going to
talk about the run of the river models
so the components that you have is
something called a where that diverts a
chunk of the water into your tube you
generally have a settling basin so that
any debris settles out because you don't
want it going into your turbine because
you'll destroy your turbine a4 Bay which
is a small holding tank so you're
getting reserved capacity that way but
that's talking about like variation on
the order of seconds or minutes not days
or months penstock which is a closed
pipe flowing downhill that feeds
directly into your turbine that then
generates your electricity and then the
water is returned back to the river
there's a lot of different turbine types
so the one of the most efficient if not
the most efficient is called a Pelton
wheel and you can see it's got a
relatively complex geometry and so
relatively expensive and challenging to
build but if you do it's it's very
efficient it works well for a high head
low flow situation so again head is how
far the water is dropping
Francis wheels which work better for
lower head higher flow which has a high
a spiral casing where the water comes in
and spins this turbine and then comes
out cross flow where the water flows
over this cylinder which has a bunch of
blades on it and that's what spins the
spins the wrote is a shaft to generate
electricity a propeller which literally
uses a ship's propeller and instead of
the ship's with polar being powered in
order to move the boat it's just using
it in the exact opposite way and you can
see that these you know you need
different types of turbines for
different flow and head situations and
then one example is just literally
putting something in the river skipping
that all that extra stuff of filtering
of siphoning off the water and just
putting something on top of the water
which seems really simple and great
until you think about like all the
challenges in terms of flooding and
debris in the water and etc etc this
this is a device that is really prone to
failure but it works in areas where
that's your only option
or it can work yeah
so some of the considerations you need
for micro-hydro one is that the minimum
head and flow you need is three feet of
head and 20 gallons per minute of flow
so that would be the minimum head you
need and if you have more head either
bonus you get more power or you can
therefore have reduced flow because the
the power equation here is again a
coefficient of efficiency times the
water density and gravity times the
height which is your head and Q which is
your flow rate so you can see that H Q
you can keep constant if you you know if
you increase your head you can lower
your velocity and keep your power
constant one nice just rule of thumb is
if you stick with SI units rho g is
about 10 you can just plug that in
rather than having to remember the
density of water and gravity though in
SI units that's relatively easy but if
ten is a nice way to just remember it
and then efficiency is somewhere be
generally between 40 and 70 percent one
other thing to think about is just when
you have your pen stock go so that's the
water going through the pipe to get from
the top of the river down to your
generator if your pipe diameter is too
small the you're gonna have frictional
losses in the pipe that dominate and
slow your water down so much that it's
problematic so that's another things to
remember because it's tempting to use
small diameter pipe for a variety of
reasons but that's dangerous so how do
you figure out if a river is appropriate
for using micro hydro so the two things
you need to know again are flow and head
so the simplest method I can find for
measuring flow it's called a float
method and you can imagine actually
doing this in a river would be
challenging so it's not trivial but it
is possible
so you mark about a hundred feet along a
length that's ideally straight with
human deform length and depth or width
and depth which is comical to find in a
river right like I've never found a
river that has a hundred feet of uniform
width and depth but you do your best and
then you calculate your cross-sectional
area a people usually model it as a
semicircle or a trapezoid or even just a
rectangle calculate that cross-sectional
area you place a marker at the start and
end of your hundred feet and then you
put floats in the river at the center of
the stream and time them to find out how
long it takes for them to get from one
end to the other if you want to get
complicated you can put them all along a
bunch of different points at different
levels to worry about friction losses
but you don't actually have to do that
to get a ballpark measurement you can
just do it in the center and so and good
floats it could be a tennis ball could
be an apple or something like that
whatever you can find that floats and
then you do have to use a conversion
factor because your water is flowing
faster at the top of the water than in
the the river than in the center because
because of the friction associated with
the the base of the river and so you
have to you can use a coefficient just
to correct and then you get your flow
rate yay so that was a lot of work and
all you have is a flow rate for one day
and water varies like flow rate varies
tremendously during the season so again
you can do your ten ten year study or
you can just get some data on annual
precipitation and when is the rainy
season the dry season and do your best
to estimate but yeah so that's how you'd
get your flow rate and then in terms of
head the simplest method that again that
I found that's used is you take a
yardstick or a stick of known length and
doesn't need to be a yardstick and you
put on it just a tube that's clear
has the ends capped that's half full of
water and that's a really cheap level
basically or you can get a real level if
you have a real level but if you don't
have a real level you can just use a
cheap level and then you hopefully with
two people you put the stick at the
bottom or the top and then just keep
moving it over and over again until you
measure your head which is a pain but
people do it and it works and actual
surveying equipment is really expensive
and so you're unlikely to have that in
the field so if your partner asked about
this you have a method to measure that's
plausible yeah right
so for the flow measurement you're
putting the your floats in the water and
watching how long it takes to get from
one end to the other and that'll give
you a measure of flow and then your
river ideally is let me get a picture
instead of trying to draw a bad picture
so your River is hypothetically going
down the mountain here and sort of doing
a curve and so you're saying okay well
I'm gonna put my weir and everything up
here and I'm going to put my location
where I'm going to actually generate the
power down here so I need to calculate
the height from right here to right here
to get my head height so now I need to
you know very painfully go up the
mountain
in order to figure out exactly how high
this distance is does that clear it up
okay
okay so that wraps up micro-hydro are
there any questions
in addition okay so trip I won't start
talking about the trip and spend
actually the rest of the time talking
about it so yeah let's do that
so one change is that one group of
students is going to go to El Salvador
now instead of Nicaragua and the reason
for that is Amy Smith just came back
from a trip to El Salvador where she
found a community partner that's really
interested in Austin we think they're
doing great work in our solid connection
and so we decided to see if we get a
dannika El Salvador and we're able to in
about two hours which is remarkably fast
compared to like the months it takes to
develop relations with other community
partners so hopefully that's a good sign
and they're really interested in
charcoal which is something you'll be
trained in next week so it just seemed
like a good fit so and you've already
know about this group so I'll talk to
you offline if you want about it
but yeah so we're excited to be working
with them so one group of students is
going to be going to El Salvador and
then two teams will be going to
Nicaragua and El Salvador doesn't border
Nicaragua but it's pretty close so we're
not that spread out yet we're not we're
not approaching do you have development
quite yet so the teams are as follows so
also Phoenix will be going to well bus
roster and Breanna will be going to also
Phoenix and Carter you'll be working
with them for the start of the term just
I don't know if I've mentioned this the
teams that you go with to the projects
you work on it for the proof for the
spring break trip may or may not be what
you end up working on afterwards so what
happens is the week after you get back
from Spring Break we sort of figure out
what projects are going to happen you
tell me what you prefer to work on and
some students are really psyched to stay
on the projects that you went on spring
break and naturally I'm going to try to
make you
make it possible for you to stay on the
project you're really psyched about and
especially if you're knowledgeable about
it cuz you just want a spring break trip
great but if for whatever reason you're
like you know what I can't stand us at
Phoenix I don't want to work with them
or anything projects over again I'm not
gonna force you I'm hopefully not gonna
be it have to force you to stay on that
so there may be a little shuffling so
especially with people who aren't
travelling there's variation and I'm
pretty sure Eric has dropped the class
so but if he hasn't he would be on this
group so the projects that you're gonna
be working on one is a last year the
students worked on the ODE a bag sealer
and so one thing is delivering that bag
sealer which ideally means reading the
final report from last year and learning
how it works so you can show it to us a
Phoenix staff when you get there and
that's sort of like the side service II
project as opposed to the investigative
parts of the work and then the one two
and three are the projects that you're
going to be investigating so one is the
bio digester which is they have bio
digesters and they want to be able to
mix internally so that the slew provides
better digestion and they're looking at
either hand or bicycle power and they
have both concrete and plastic bio
digesters a second is a feed chopper
mechanism using bicycle power and I can
show you video the feed chopper and
third is a washing machine
do you have actually has done a lot of
work on washing machines and so this is
one area where you can learn about the
existing washing machines designs and
then potentially bring them down and
even build one while you're there it's a
possibility and I at the end of going
through all this I'm going to talk about
what you need to do with this
information in the next few weeks and
then you'll have time to work with your
teams talk to me a little bit your
mentor if will show up at 2:00 to work
with you a little bit on all of this the
second group of wan desica Elizabeth
Vivian
Syd and Kurt is going a group of Phoenix
Emilia survey is your trip leader she
took the class this class last year
and did a summer fellowship at grupo
Phoenix and so she knows them pretty
well and she's a grad student now and so
the projects are number one they're
really interested in charcoal both the
stove and a stove project that was
worked on last year on making charcoal
generally so working with them on
charcoal - solar cell phone chargers to
develop more affordable conversion for
production they currently are working on
developing a cell phone charger I can
show you the battery charger they have
in is pretty rudimentary and partly
that's a function of their poverty and
availabe of materials but there is
opportunity to improve it and they would
like to have a really good solar cell
phone charger and then three they have a
solar cooker that's really expensive
I'll talk about it next week some and
there's a lot of opportunity for
improvement there to make it more
affordable to reduce and more
aesthetically pleasing and more
functional - we have some data on there
and then the third group in El Salvador
is called a so pro SAR and so Ben Z
Missy and Yulia will be going there and
Adrian and Benji you'll be on that team
- and so the projects so they're
interesting our charcoal training and
that again so that would be sort of the
service part better ventilation for
smoke in the home is one area of
interest we believe secondly is we think
charcoal stoves will be relevant in El
Salvador based on what I remember of my
trip there I'm pretty sure they cook
with Adobe stoves just like they do in
Nicaragua so it'll be relevant to work
on the stove project there and then
potentially better lighting
opportunities - and a lot of these are
sort of having a bit of an architectural
bent which we haven't focused on much in
this class but Yulia is a grad student
architecture so she's gonna help with
that aspect of things
guess what so yeah so we're excited
about that project and thanks for the
people who are rolling with just being
sent to a new country very little notice
so what do you have to do with all this
so right now and by right now I mean in
the next two hours talk to me and do
some brainstorming of ideas and your
deliverable for this step is to animate
annotated pictures from each team member
and so there's a lot of different
deadlines for all these different things
I'm just trying to help you get through
the next couple of weeks in a way that
you actually get output and don't save
it all to the last night which will lead
to really weak both packing and help for
your community partner so this is all
hopefully in preparation so that you can
maximize the value to you and your
community partner for the spring break
trip and for the people who aren't
traveling you're helping make sure
they're maximizing their their work and
it's also getting you prepared for doing
the project work after the spring break
so I don't think this is busy work for
you in any way so so that's one is doing
a brainstorming effort and I'm going to
talk a little bit about brainstorming in
a minute so you have some guidelines
there yeah it seemed technology or like
juice
no just sketches so yeah so basically
I'll show you this in a minute but when
you do a brainstorm like if I was
brainstorming wind turbines I might do a
picture that looks like that you know
like takes me ten seconds to draw tops
and for the pictures you and that would
be really appropriate our brainstorming
session for the pictures you turn in I'd
want it to be a little more refined so
that this is everything is drawn a
little bit more carefully there's a few
more elements that actually make this a
real device rather than just something
disembodied an air whatever is
appropriate not many if any of you are
artists right or technical graphic
designers and so I'm not looking for an
amazing sketch that was done by a
graphic designer or artist I'm not one
either
but if you just draw relatively slowly
and carefully you know maybe do a couple
tries you should be able to get a
drawing that looks decent enough that
it's understandable which is all I'm
really looking for so then the second
thing is a literature search on the
topic which you may have time for as
well but I want you to do a brainstorm
initially just to sort of get creative
before you know what's out there
necessarily so then so that's why we're
doing them brainstorm one brainstorming
first but then a second set which you
may have time to do some today if you
brought laptops or what have you is to
get some information on what's out there
so that you're more informed about
whatever you need to be whatever your
project is there's and so the what I
think wouldn't be a good deliverable for
this is an annotated bibliography and
there's guidelines right there on how to
write an annotated bibliography the
guidelines for annotating big augur keys
are generally on the like liberal arts
side of things
and so they talk about summarizing what
with the content reflecting on whether
it was useful and assessing the quality
of the source and all those things are
good things but basically I want you to
focus on summarizing what was there and
reflecting on how it's relevant to your
project for each annotation and
assessing the quality of the source if
it's a crappy source just don't include
it in the bibliography and if it's a
great source include it and if there is
something to assess that you want to
note don't don't hesitate to but
otherwise you don't really have the time
to spend time assessing the source in a
written form so third is developing
project specifications and to double-a 9
does a really nice job of defining what
a project specification is so I've
provided links to their lecture and
examples and so you're going to provide
project specifications for each project
using the 2.9 format so that would mean
an attribute metric a unit and a value
and you'll see the definitions there the
value is an actual number like it means
like a 3 or a 7 and a lot of those
numbers you probably won't be able to
fill in until after your trip and that's
fine but I would what I would like you
to do is come with the best guess even
if it's a range of a couple of orders of
magnitude come with the best guess so
that when you talk to your community
partner who often don't have a lot of
comfort with numbers and may give you
really wacky numbers if they're giving
you numbers that are completely
different from what you're expecting
that's a really good indicator to you
that you need to keep asking questions
so that either you learn that your
assumptions are totally off which is a
really important thing to learn or that
your community partner isn't really
understanding the question or doesn't
have the educational background to be
able to give you a useful number and you
have to work and a few different guises
to actually get to that number and we'll
talk about that on the trip prep week of
how you actually do that process of
getting that information and then the
next aspects are doing a second
brainstorm and it's up to you as a team
if you want to do this in two stages so
sometimes people like to brainstorm on
their own for a bit and then come
together and bring those ideas to a
brainstorm and also build on more in a
group brainstorm session some people
prefer just to do a group brainstorming
session so it's up to you but the second
brainstorm should at least have a group
component and for those it's just too
animated annotated pictures for each
project
and so it's fewer pictures because it's
it's not 14-member and so you guys can
just figure out how you want to split
those up another thing is the big
questions you have that you want to make
sure you get answered so that you have
those in mind so that you make sure the
end of the trip you've gotten answers to
those questions and all of these
questions are related to figuring out
can you actually work on this project is
this a good project and if you are gonna
work on it what what is the appropriate
deliverable that's the type of questions
a materials list for the trip so you may
well need some materials if you're gonna
do a charcoal demonstration if you're
gonna try to build a washing machine if
you have a great idea for a project and
you want to try to actually implement
either a prototype or something in the
field your community partner needs to
know so that they can provide the
materials and/or we need to get them
here so that we can bring them down and
so I put that you don't need this until
the 16th which is right before the trip
and that's only if like that's the last
desperate time if you can define them
sooner that's better so that you can be
your partner has time to get them and/or
we have time to get them if you need
help but know those questions materials
earlier okay good that makes more sense
and then finally on the 16th you're
gonna do about a 15 minute presentation
on your literature literature search
findings your project specifications the
annotated pictures the key questions and
your key expected activities just so
that you're well prepared for the trip
so that's basically the assignments
apart from a little bit of reading for
the next few weeks
which again violates the syllabus but
hopefully will work out so or be okay
with you guys but I didn't want to add
problem sets on top of this because this
is a lot of work are there any questions
about all of this I have it printed out
so that when you're working on it today
you have something to refer to
yeah yeah so most people are flying on
what are people so people going to
Nicaragua are flying on Sunday and
getting back on the following Sunday
what about El Salvador unless so one and
Jessica have personal commitments so
they're flying back on Friday and do you
know what El Salvador is doing yet I
mean okay so I'll solve it or maybe
travelling a day early earlier
yeah the 18th is the Friday so the
Sunday would be 20th and we'll send out
your actual itinerary soon some of the
tickets are booked others are just
reserved and we'll be booking them today
so there's a couple of reading
assignments that'll be up on stellar
shortly this is just a somewhat
different perspective from the Paul
Pollock reading you did and then this is
directions on charcoal making so both
are quite short so I know it might be
seeming like a lot but these are very
manageable to get done so now I just
want to go over how to do brainstorming
and then we can take a break and then
you can get into your project groups and
do brainstorming I start talking about
the trip and then to your mentors will
show up unless your mentors I meet he's
already here a trip trip leader and so
you can get support from them as well
and get to know them so effective and
fun brainstorming you require a clear
problem statement so for this case
you're it's whatever the project idea is
for your community partner project after
the after you get back from Spring Break
you have about four weeks of building
and you have about a five hundred dollar
budget so while you'll see I'm gonna
encourage you to have really wild ideas
and so if you come up with a idea that
completely violates the four weeks of
building in the 500 budgets still throw
it out there it's nice to have in your
mind a general sense of these sorts of
things
so that you're not only brainstorming
things that are in the like seven
megawatt wind turbine category if you're
thinking about wind power so for fun and
effective brainstorming you're trying to
generate as many ideas as you can in 15
minutes
so 15 minutes is a good length of time
sometimes you need a little more a
little less but around that time for any
particular project statement and then
you can say take a break take a stretch
and then come back and work on the next
problem statement you want your sketch
to really be a picture with a few words
so a lot of people if you know they're
brainstorming weapons of war and you
have your eight and a half piece of
paper might draw this
and I would say that this picture is a
lot more evocative of what your idea is
then using the words big and the you
know just a tiny drawing and those of us
who are not so good at drawing and I'm
one of them are tempted to draw really
small because you don't want to show in
really big format just how bad your
drawing is but even being a weak drawer
you can still get your idea across
pretty well this is like a three minute
sketch for an artist so none of your
brainstorm ideas are gonna look this
crafted this might be some the actual
annotated sketch that you turn in that
you actually refine and spend some time
on so you know the ten-second version is
gonna be a guy and you have a guy and
he's shooting stuff and here's the
person who's unhappy getting shot at and
then here's the wheel that's moving your
wall of doom right so this is a really
fast version of that sketch and so
that's what I'm looking for not that but
I just wanted to emphasize it's most
people start out he's doing this and you
really want to force yourself to do that
with maybe you know the description at
the top or the bottom but the picture
should dominate not the words yeah
okay yeah so the three projects so if
one of your projects was the feed
shopper right now you know nothing about
that project right so you may not be
able to brainstorm that at all until you
come talk to me which is part of what
you need to do in the next hour and a
half is come talk to me so I can give
each team a little bit more detail about
their three projects
but one of them like might be something
you you can brainstorm on initially if
there's a queue to wait for me
but either way once you know a little
bit about the feed chopper then that'll
be one of your brainstorming assignments
is the the project the community partner
needs this this mechanization of it the
feed chopper and let's brainstorm ways
to mechanize that feed chopper and just
put out as many ideas as you can in 15
minutes and a good goal is to be
generating like at least three ideas per
minute which doesn't sound like that
many but it's pretty challenging but
that is sort of something to keep in
your mind is I should be generating
three ideas per minute and so if I'm not
I need to get crazier probably and less
inhibited in order to successfully do it
and so once you draw this beautiful
picture with your group what you do is
everyone's hopefully drawing and you
just say hey guys my idea is an
advancing wall of doom and then you grab
a piece of tape and we're going to use
the the three fume hoods as our boards
so each group will be around a fume hood
and so just tape your idea up on the
wall and then get back on drying and if
Kurt you had said this advancing wall of
doom and I love that idea I can say yeah
it's gonna be an advancing wall of doom
but instead of being wheel powered it's
gonna be on on a big wheel powered it's
going to be in a bunch of little wheels
and so in other circles that might be
considered theft right and you'd be
really mad at me for stealing your idea
but on brainstorming that's really
encouraged is to quote steal people's
ideas so have no worry about that you
guys can work out your patent ray
if you become millionaires over your
dancing wall of doom later so what are
the rules of the game so one is deferred
judgment so when I propose that I want
to make a wind turbine that's just gonna
float in the air magically with helium
balloons and you see a few flaws in that
idea you just have to bite your tongue
and the one way you can manage that is
by saying okay I'm gonna still take your
you know I'm gonna build on your idea
and instead of helium balloons we're
gonna use a post that's attached to the
ground so but deferred judgment even of
your own ideas and of anyone else's you
know if you're showing your idea no
saying this is really stupid but here it
is to say what it is hopefully everyone
is coming up with some really terrible
ideas as well it was really really good
ones and some of those really terrible
ones have a kernel of Awesomeness in
them and so that's why it's worth it to
get them out one at a time so if
everyone is talking at once its
ineffective so post them up one at a
time and you shouldn't draw like three
ideas on three pieces of on one piece of
paper you should have each piece of
paper for each idea as I mentioned so
building on ideas so theft is encouraged
don't be afraid of that try to stay
focused which can be hard spending 15
minutes trying to generate three ideas
per minute that's a lot of ideas but do
try to do that and then as I mentioned
be visual and incur use wild ideas don't
be afraid to be like yeah wall of doom
but it's gonna be made out of peanut
butter like something that ridiculous
you know just pops in your head throw it
out there because it may inspire someone
to say well not peanut butter but what
about peanut shells that would be a
really low-cost way to make it right and
all of a sudden that's a slightly useful
idea for this ridiculous wall of doom
yeah and then once you're done you can
sort the pile to divide to get them into
themes so you can sort of you know just
figure out what are your themes or what
are your combinations
figure out do those themes actually make
sense and then I'll often refine and
combine the best so those two ideas from
each group don't necessarily have to be
the ones you came up with but ones that
you think are some of the best of that
what you came up with do you guys have
questions on that I went over that kind
of fast so yeah okay so then for the
next hour and a half you guys can like
take your ten minute break and then come
back and do the brainstorming meet with
me and then please remember to fill out
your muddy cards and include the hours
per week on them so that that you think
you're spending on the class so that I I
just have a sense of how that's going
but it's sort of a big blue box with a
lid that you can open and it has like a
parabola make it oh I'm sure we can
parabola so there's a parabolic SAR you
scratch it out such a problem with just
basically kind of stealing the idea for
me and I guess our sole source these are
sort of cookies and they're trained
animal is and they're really these
they're really Mobile's that we can fold
them up and carry them around that's a
big no-no you can
in box and parabolic solar thing heating
some kind of heating element so did that
be like really good yeah that's a liquid
and oh oh shoot so it'll have to cycle
back
you
you